Uh, Can of Truth is out here in St.
Louis, Missouri
at a big huge Christian event. It's
going on for 11 days. That's why you
haven't been seeing much uh live stuff
going on on the channel. Bear with us.
We are working on so many so many cool
things. I can't wait for you guys to see
the stuff that we got coming out. I'm
busting up in here with some
Aby's books, some God's you yet t-shirts
that you guys probably haven't even
seen, the God's not done with you yet
t-shirts, but they are on our
uh on our website, kofruth.org. Look at
this place.
I'm here a little early right now, so it
might not be as busy as it as it will be
later. But check this out, guys. This is
amazing.
It was so busy yesterday
being Saturday. I couldn't even move.
Couldn't take a break. Like, it's crazy.
This is uh
it's bigger than it looks. I'm about to
show you guys, but I wanted to to update
you guys that we're out here doing
things. Man, can of Truth is on the
move. We got three events coming up uh
next month. one in
Kentucky called Spiracy Con put on by
Now You See TV. If you guys are going to
be in the Kentucky area, get your
tickets. Come out there. It's going to
be awesome. There's going to be a lot of
great speakers. conspiracy con that is
next month in Kentucky from Now You See
TV. Um,
in August and
September, I think, are the months,
we're going to be at Truther Con. We're
going to be at International Truth Expo.
We're out here doing things, guys, and
it's all because of you. We can't do it
without you. I just want to let you know
because I'm not sure if everybody knows
that kind of stuff. When it comes to
YouTubers, they think they're sitting
around in pajamas, you know, looking up
videos and say, "Hey, we should do
something on that." It's It's a lot.
We're out here promoting.
We're out here going to I go to a a a
local nursing home once a month and give
Bible studies and presentations.
We are at youth groups. We are at
churches. We're at events.
uh schools. So if you guys want to
invite Candid Truth to come to your
event, your school, your church, you can
book us on candidruth.org and check out
the booking. But I want to show you guys
this. This place is huge. I think I
think Strange Normal might be around
here somewhere. Check this out.
Little Light Studios. You're live,
Denique. What's up? What's up? What's
up, Keith? You're live, bro. Hey,
you guys are printing t-shirts right on
the spot. That's what's up. Yes, we are.
Check that. Hey, you guys got to check
out the Little Light booth. If you're
here in St. Louis, check out Little
Light Studios. Get you a custom t-shirt.
Hey man, this is networking central out
here. So, let me see. Oh, this is where
Brad Brad from Strange Normal is. Is
that That's not him. But look at these
Hello. Hey. I was looking to see if Brad
was around. We're We're live. So, I
don't know if you guys care. You're
live. Yeah. See, this is soap for real,
man. Oh, real soap for real men. I'm a
real man. We got 30 30 people watching.
So, cool. So, wellness secrets. Wellness
secrets. I've been telling uh telling
Brad to let everybody know. We're in
Northwest Arkansas. If you want to come
and see us at 7:18 the booth is awesome.
Yep. Come get your health on. Uhhuh. I
haven't seen Brad. over here. Brad's
slacking. He's sleeping in. I got an
interview over here, but I was just
showing everybody where we're at. You
guys, keep up the great work.
Hey everybody. I can't see who all is in
here. Realize the phone is interesting.
Let's see. Where are you? St. Louis,
Missouri at the
general conference. It's huge. There's
Oh my goodness. There's Michelle Dukeus,
the one and only. We're live. So, what's
up everybody? Yeah. Good to see you.
Everybody's here, guys.
I'm about to do an interview with uh Oh,
look. Amazing Facts. Ever heard of them?
Yeah, they're they're a little ministry.
You might have heard of them. Uh,
everybody's out here, man. This is huge.
Doug Bachelor might be here.
Wait, here he is right here. Doug, dude,
what's up, bro?
Me and Doug, you're just kicking it.
What do you got to say, Doug? Man, I
love Candid Truth. You guys keep up the
great work out there. You're really
killing it. Thanks, Doug. It really
means a lot, man. What about a Can of
Truth interview? You see that anytime
soon? Absolutely. We're going to be
doing some great interviews. Come out
anytime, brother. Thanks, man. That
really means a lot. So, met some great
people here at the Amazing Facts,
including one.
He he believes he believes the truth
about the earth. His name is Jacob.
What's up, bro? You're live, man. I
don't know. This is my boy Jacob from
Amazing Facts. You might a little little
ministry called Amazing Facts.
You're on Can of Truth, bro?
So, uh this interview is
with uh man, they're doing podcast right
here.
They're literally doing a podcast live.
Check this out.
There's the control center. Keep up the
great work, man.
Mission spotlight.
This is nuts. If you guys are in the St.
Louis area, come to the general
conference. Lots of Christian ministries
out here. So, I'm fixing to do this
interview with Button to Christ.
This ministry is amazing. I'll tell you,
these people are the only ministry I
know right now that are legit doing
deliverance ministry.
literally doing the great commission
that Jesus told us to do. Go out into
all the world, sick, cast out devils,
raise the dead. They're doing it. I
don't know anybody else that's doing it,
saying, "Call into our line. We will
pray with you. We will fast with you."
They prayed for my mom when she was in
the hospital. And they prayed
diligently. They would call and be on
the phone for over an hour with a a
group
of prayer warriors, man, fasting and
praying.
And uh so about to do an interview with
them. I love you guys. We can't do this
without you. I see some of the comments
in there from Scott and Escor says, "Is
he a flatearther?" Yes, he is. Biblical
cosmologist, we like to say. Let me
scroll through real quick. Uh, tell Brad
we can't do this without you. Come on
out to St. Louis, Missouri. It's going
on for another week. It'll be here for
another whole week every day. And um,
we're just out here doing things. I just
want to let you guys know what's going
on. If you think the channel's been
getting stagnant, not hasn't hasn't been
uh, another live lately, I just wanted
to go live, let you guys know we're out
here doing things because of you. We
can't do without you. We love you guys.
God bless you and we'll see you soon on
another episode. Candid Truth.
I never know how to get out of this
thing.
40 seconds.